[Music]
pete's so nice to see you how are you
i'm doing well it's nice to be here yeah
a lot of talk about mothers did you know
that your mother and my father actually
go to the same bakery they do that's
true where where lindell's bakery on
massachusetts avenue i know that bakery
is on massachusetts that's right
my mom does go there that that is why my
father thinks you have me on the show
really i'm not kidding i call home i'm
like pop i'm doing the conan show and
he's like bring it up
why why why do you think they have you
on the program all those times and i'll
be like i don't know uh he seems to
enjoy my sense of humor we have a
similar sensibility he's like does he
mention the bakery peter
and the fact that we're from boston and
that we're very similar heights he's
convinced that's the only reason why you
have me on the show really he thinks
those are that just because i found out
that your mom goes to the same bakery as
mine i'd like to see the booker being
like we'd love to have this guy on the
show uh what bakery does his father go
to
i gotta get that cleared right up top
let's figure it out i don't care why you
have me on i'm just glad to be here yeah
it sounds like your dad doesn't think
you're very funny
no they are very supportive oh well
that's good i'm not i'm not his cup of
tea but you know
i think i don't know why two people
applauded the idea that i'm here and
that yeah that really made me feel quite
terrible i'm criticizing your posture
right now i'm looking this thing the way
look at the way you're slumping in the
chair
i don't know you're like down here
you're like all right let's do this i'm
trying to project that i'm very
comfortable and honest and real yeah and
that your low back is out
i don't know what the problem is
oh those are mine very nice
okay let's talk about
television okay uh what what shows you
watching these days i'll tell you what
i'm not watching is a game of thrones
which hold your applause that's okay i
know everybody tells me it's the most
fantastic show do you watch it i love
game of thrones i watch every episode
see no you're right everybody else is
right i'm wrong i don't know why i can't
get into it and i've been thinking about
it recently i think i figured it out
it's uh it's realms
realms yeah
any show that has realms i'm out
what are you talking about i didn't know
that was a deal breaker but if a man on
a horse gets off in like a foggy wood
and goes in this realm i'm like nope
forget this show
i can't do it
these magical stones work in this realm
but not the nether realms i just turn it
off i can't have realms no realms it
sounds like seinfeld no realms
villages cities townships ramps now
so that's out for that whole thing all
right and
donnie cheese were talking about british
accents donnie cheese donnie chad's oh
wow that's what the cool people call
them i didn't know i didn't even meet
them
i call them d cheeds but anyway
i took a chance uh-huh but yeah british
accents we were talking about we were
talking about well if you watch game of
thrones or if you watch like lord of the
rings anytime there's like a fantasy
movie or tv show they all talk in a
british accent which is another thing
that takes me out of it because that's a
real
that's a real place yeah great britain
people currently in the future are using
that voice it's a real thing but
whenever we want to make it feel like
another planet or another realm yeah use
that accent yes
i guess it's because
any other one would sound if you're like
these two dwarves just store my horse
jesus christ
they've got horse smugglers in this
realm
it's just a magical arrow bro
i'm sorry to say on the show but that's
why what a great apology by the way i
say so many stop it
there's no reason
it's how i do your father is watching
what are they gonna say at the bakery
that was great
cookies
[Applause]